okay so bigger there's classify angles
right now let's take another little
subheading okay and this is the last
thing we were saying you which is about
yes on different sums of angles now when
we combine egg was in different ways and
find the sum of each one
sometimes they're important we give them
special mayor's so for instance here's
our here's our first one okay if you
have two angles you put them together
like this a and B and if you add love
together and you get a right angle in
there
okay we say that a and B would be added
into gonna be at 90 so we call them
complementary not like as in you know
wow that meal was fantastic which is
complement with an i but this is
complementary and then they go together
okay like that wine and that fish are
very complementary okay question that's
right so if they add up to to 90 degrees
then they called complementary okay now
if we have another two angles that's
called C and D and instead of adding up
to 90 degrees they have 280 to a
straight line again we have a special
sauce named close they don't know what
it is very similar to this
yeah something else so the supplementary
that's right so here C and D are
supplementary
that's okay I'm welcome to look around
go for anything like that because
because see degrees plus D degrees
equals country okay now this goes along
with the fact that if you put any bunch
of ends together it could be two or
three or four or five or five hundred if
they all the straight line together they
are always gonna add up to immunity so
that was comp entry a supplementary was
be there to 180 okay
two more which are very similar to this
and then we'll finish you'll be here but
will they go parallel lines we're gonna
get that next lesson yeah that's all
that parallel lines will get there we
get that not tomorrow the day after yes
yep yep so supplementary means you're
gonna pair mangos paramedic books and
they add up to 180 so for example 100
and a hundred degrees introduced a piece
of metric or 1990 or 10 and 170 you add
them together in the other day
different size yeah 90 here of what
anything okay last two little bits here
to fish again one peak event when you
add up the angles now if you've got
scissors there probably most of you
don't but if you do I want you to kind
of triangle have a piece of paper you
get like the scrap in there like that I
can only do one well you don't even need
to you can tear up a triangle into like
three pieces like they can be really
awesome outage okay
X Y okay since you guys watch nothing up
my sleeve okay now if I think about the
three different angles that I have here
so I'm calling the next Y and Zed they
all have a really special relationship
no matter what trivia I could cut
another one like I was in I wasn't
paying particular station of what kind
of triangle I caught right if I get let
me let me measure so labeled for you
you came back and see the miss alright
now if I cut them and took the little
sign each other okay let's do so I got X
here right now if I draw that I'm gonna
draw it on because I don't have any
mistake so there's my X you happy with
that
I'll hold up against it okay wait is why
there it is let's put him there so
that's kind of off like that that's why
yeah do that you see that yeah okay last
one here it is okay there we go
okay now what I put them all together
this is my x y&z together okay yeah more
everything actually
okay and you till you come together how
are you trying to become more my soluz
if you like and do it you can almost see
it here all the way across right that is
a straight angle right so any two angles
in any triangle X plus y plus Z is equal
to what's the size of training 180 good
name next 20 so I could say that with a
sentence I could say the angle sum which
is the sum of all the angles he angry
sum of a triangle is 1
one a3z sped up because actually if that
isn't what nudism going okay now I said
I was going to show you one last one
this is the same thing last one okay I
can do it you can go down the page but
I've run out of white one space so he's
my last one okay we just did the English
sum of a triangle which is three angles
what's a shake cool but it's got four
angles
it's got a quadrilateral isn't it okay
curtain that I made full size so I am
interested in the angles so now name for
me name for me some kinds of
quadrilaterals you know because we
actually know a whole bunch yeah Rick
tango give me another one square give me
another one wrong boots do another one
trapezium we need for science where yes
okay now I'm gonna suggest I'm gonna
suggest that all of them no matter what
kind of portrait level they are they all
have the same angle so here's the way
I'm going to show you let me draw some
we won't keep looking it's pretty one
gets so one key because that side not
even straight
okay now I've deliberately tried to draw
it and I'd like you to try and throw it
too so none of the sides are equal none
of the sides of parallel is just a weird
four shape four-sided shape
that'll do if you join just make sure
there are no sides now have a look at it
I can actually break up this
quadrilateral I can break it up into two
triangles Connor yeah I can do it a
couple of different ways what's one way
I could do it if I cool it and they see
so now I've got two triangles I could
have got AC as well but it won't matter
tell me this triangle a B D what's the
angle of so we just said it 20 what
about the other one the small one
BCD what's it do it's straight right so
now if I take both of them you gotta add
them up right
yeah and with some requested item is 180
now don't forget how I Ellis traited
this with the triangle you remember I
got triangle I cut it apart I put all
the angles next to each other and what
did I get when I put all the angles here
together what did I get I got a
straining did not that's why I said one
day if you make for yourself the
contralateral someone can borrow these
right if you cut out all the angles and
you stick them together what should you
expect right I want you to try it I want
you to try it